et l'actualité maintenant de la campagne
présidentielle la candidate lr valérie
pécresse s'est entretenu avec nicolas
sarkozy elle qui doit réunir à plusieurs
milliers de personnes ce dimanche au
zénith de paris pour un grand meeting du
côté du rassemblement national marine le
pen était en déplacement à toulon pour
présenter son programme concernant la
défense nationale au moment où un
sondage bva orange pour rtl dévoilé ce
matin place emmanuel macron en pole
position devant marine le pen suivi de
près par valérie pécresse au coude à
coude avec eric zemmour décryptage avec
arnaud benedetti et rédacteur en chef de
la revue politique et parlementaire et
frédéric sinclair politologue
l'éditorialiste
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france on entend
beaucoup parler de l'éventuelle duel à
maquereau le pen au second tour de la
confrontation le pen est mort un peu
moins du duel pécresse le pen est ce
qu'il existe frédéric sinclar est ce que
c'est le duel oublier au delà des
intentions de vote et les sondages
le duel de second tour pécresse le pen
qui n'existe pas encore dans l'est dans
les sondages je vois mal même comment il
pourrait
s'inscrire dans une dans une réalité en
revanche
on a on à faire une espèce de
d'ascenseur
électorale un tout petit peu particulier
on a annoncé le elle est le mouvement
ait l'air mort cérébrale mans depuis la
défaite de françois fillon il n'a pas
réussi à reprendre vie il ya eu
différentes périodes on les connais je
vais pas y revenir et puis il ya eu ce
congrès l air qui a été une forme de
résurrection de l air à vrai dire la
résurrection ça a été l'apparition d'
eric ciotti c'est vraiment ça la
véritable résurrection de mahler sauf
que il échoue au second tour par un
conservatisme par une frilosité d'une
partie des militants emmenés par les
dirigeantes fédé en région derrière
xavier bertrand derrière barnier qui qui
qui ont envie de ramener eux
hier vers quelque chose de plus modérée
de plus centriste et finalement de plus
macro nhien et donc c'est valérie
pécresse qui l'emportent ils aujourd'hui
l'image d'une valérie pécresse proche
d'eric ciotti pendant le congrès parce
que elle a fait la nique à
xavier bertrand d'un côté et michel
barnier de l'autre et bien cette image
là d'une valérie pécresse assez dur
droite dans ses bottes elle commence à
s'effriter on commence à se dire mais
finalement qui ce qui est cette femme là
est-ce que ceux se ses alliances avec le
lui dis avec le très contesté jean
christophe lagarde est ce que est ce que
c'est plus plus révélateur que sa
proximité avec eric ciotti ou est ce
qu'elle se situe et on se rend compte qu
elle s'effrite et c'est pour ça qu'on
commence à se poser la question de
marine le pen et de valérie pécresse
parce que où on est en train de se dire
mon bac comment va se jouer l'entrée au
second tour je crois qu'il ya une chose
qu'il faut pas minimiser c'est le
troisième homme c'est eric zemmour eric
zemmour et les traits barre il a heurté
un plafond de verre au moment de sa
déclaration
mais il est possible qu aujourd'hui son
discours sur une droite civilisationnel
allié à un discours sur
possiblement une économie libérale
puisse renforcer sa base et que sur le
dernier mois et bien on est un jeu
d'équilibré comme ça entre les trois
personnages finalement on est une
indécision emmanuel macron assez loin et
puis finalement les trois autres le
scénario alternatif ça serait une
valérie pécresse qui s'effondre et qui
passe en troisième voire quatrième
position hardinvast des métiers qu'est
ce qui distingue selon vous les deux
candidats de valérie pécresse marine le
pen et qu'est ce qui les rassemble aussi
écouter aujourd'hui il est clair que si
vous voulez pécresse essaie de tenir les
deux bouts de la chaîne c'est-à-dire
désir de droite clairement affirmée par
le vote en faveur d'eric ciotti comme ça
a été rappelé lors du congrès et puis
neil centriste avec laquelle elle a loué
une alliance afin de montrer qu'elle
était capable de faire une synthèse dans
ce qui reste est aujourd'hui des
républicains
après la différence fondamentale entre
marine le pen zemmour à côté et valérie
pécresse c'est que
les deux candidats le pen et zemmour ont
finalement des discours politiques qui
sont beaucoup plus différenciée beaucoup
plus différenciables beaucoup plus
audible pour la plupart des électeurs
joie qui en tout cas les électeurs de
droite donc ça je crois qu'en effet ils
ont de ce point de vue là dans une
élection où il faut être capable à un
moment donné de marquer de son empreinte
le champ politique et la compétition
électorale ils sont beaucoup plus
audible beaucoup plus visible ou conclut
identifiable pour les segments
électoraux auquel il souhaite s'adresser
avec al avantage certain pour eric
zemmour qui ont en effet en ayant un
discours à la fois l'identitaire
civilisationnel et libérale est en
mesure de séduire une partie de
l'électorat de droite qui est en cherche
en effet d'un projet politique qui soit
un projet politique qui les paris en
l'occurrence à bord et politique qui
porte ces valeurs avec une petite
différence avec marine le pen qui elle
en effet de son côté bénéficient enfin
bénéficie essaye de se recentrer du fait
de l'apparition de cette offre politique
nouvelle qu'est celle d'eric zemmour est
vraisemblablement pour ce qui concerne
zemmour et marine le pen des sociologies
un peu différente et des rapports à la
politique là peu différent c'est à dire
que on peut considérer que l'électorat
d'eric zemmour est peut-être un peu plus
bourgeois un peu plus vous allez dire
structuré dans sa relation à la
politique plus mobilisés que le lait
l'électorat de marine le pen qui serait
un électorat plus populaire venant
peut-être plus de la france périphérique
et dont la relation à la politique et
certainement moins construite et moins
intense que l'électorat d'eric zemmour
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui rebond en tout
cas dans les intentions de vote marine
le pen arrive dans ce camp là en tout
cas de cette droite très large qui va de
valérie pécresse eric zemmour arrive en
tête dans les intentions de vote
avec une bonne capacité de résistance de
sa part quand même il faut être clair là
dessus c'est à dire que à résister à la
première dynamique d'eric zemmour qui
certes a pris une partie de l'électorat
de son électorat mais elle a réussi
aussi à résister à la deuxième dynamique
était celle de valérie pécresse il faut
se souvenir lorsqu'elle a été désigné
par le congrès et qui a bénéficié à ce
moment là d'un petit rebond technique
qui lui a permis dans les sondages
d'être une candidate
qualifiable pour le second tour voire
même fait que son second tour on se
montre tour d'emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui manifestement plus encalminé
dans sa dans sa campagne et qui résiste
aujourd'hui toujours marine le pen
disons la la la la guerre psychologique
qui lui est menée par eric zemmour qui
eux essayent en tout cas de faire venir
vers lui un certain nombre de cadres et
d'élus du rassemblement national aura
évidemment la campagne est encore long
il reste deux mois on va voir comment ça
va se passer mais je dirais pour
leicester tout cas un petit avantage
pour marine le pen dans cette
compétition à trois marine le pen qui
était donc à toulon aujourd'hui elle a
présenté son programme pour la défense
près de cinq heures quelle posture est
ce qu'elle tombe d'encore d'incarner la
une femme d'autorité assurément une
femme de responsabilité assurément et
une femme qui comprend les enjeux
internationaux et qui s'inscrit en faux
par rapport la posture des manuels macro
et vous aura pas échappé qu'elle a
mentionné un certain nombre de traités
de londres d'aix-la-chapelle sur
lesquelles elle voulait revenir ou
qu'elle voulait renégocier
elle ne veut pas partager la
souveraineté de la france avec en
matière de défense avec la
grande-bretagne comme le traité de
londres le le prévoyait elle ne veut pas
partager la souveraineté de la france ni
en matière de défense et en matière
diplomatique comme le traité
d'aix-la-chapelle le prévoyait deux
traités qui ont été signés récemment
aix-la-chapelle c'est emmanuel macron en
2019 vous vous rappelez la polémique
autour de ce partage du siège de la
france à l'onu avait l'allemagne
emmanuel macron est un
intégrationniste invétéré il veut
absolument faire de l'europe une nation
une nation qui n'existent pas dit marine
le pen parce qu'il n'ya pas un peuple
européen il y a valls est peuple est
encore dans certains cas même des
peuples qui sont incompatibles et les
uns aux autres au sein d'une même nation
mais qui pourrait se diviser donc elle
ne croit pas du tout à l'idéologie macro
nist c'est ça qu'elle a voulu montrer
aujourd'hui je suis proche des armées je
suis une femme d'état et je suis une
femme qui a une vision géopolitique qui
est en rupture avec celle d' emmanuel
macron on voit l'échec emmanuel macron
était en ukraine était en russie à deux
jours aujourd'hui on a des mouvements de
troupes en biélorussie ça veut dire que
non seulement sa discussion avec poutine
est un est un échec parce que vladimir
poutine a laissé entendre que ce
qu'avait annoncé manuel macron n'était
pas vrai mais en plus de ça c'est un
scénario dont aujourd'hui en occident où
se demande assez souvent est ce qu'il
est vraiment viable est-ce que ce que
emmanuel macron en temps pour l'europe
élargie était réalisable est ce que ses
visées vis-à-vis de l'otan sont censurés
sont porteuses de paix marine le pen dit
non marine le pen tic je sors du
commandement intégré de l'otan
aujourd'hui à toulon c'est à dire je
rompt avec la politique d' emmanuel
macron et valérie pécresse de son côté a
donc rencontré nicolas sarkozy cet après
midi l'ancien chef de l'état qui lui a
pas encore apporté son soutien il s'est
récemment montrée à d'ailleurs très
critique vis-à-vis de sa campagne
puisque selon des révélations de la
presse il lui reprocherait de partir
dans tous les sens d'être inexistante
arnaud bel héritier en quoi est-ce que
ça aiderait valérie pécresse dans sa
compagne d'avoir le soutien nicolas
sarkozy qu'est ce qu'il pèse aujourd'hui
dans l'électorat en un mot il pèse
certainement encore dix ans au niveau
des militants mais je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de fétichiser le soutien d oeil
d autres encore une fois une élection
présidentielle à un moment donné c'est
une alchimie qui s'opère entre candidats
un moment et un peuple c'est ainsi que
le général de gaulle avait voulu
l'élection présidentielle et c'est ainsi
qu'elle s'est globalement tous pour
dérouler je rappelle que edouard
balladur en 1995 disposer du soutien de
la plupart des parlementaires du groupe
lapeyre d'un certain nombre de grandes
figures du rpr dont charles pasqua et au
final c'est jacques chirac qui l'a
emporté d'autant plus que nicolas
sarkozy aujourd'hui et aussi quand même
quelqu'un qui pour une partie de
l'électorat de droite n'est pas celui
qui a tenu les promesses qui étaient les
siennes donc par contre en effet ce qui
pose problème chez dans une campagne si
vous voulez qui a du mal à passer la
vitesse supérieure le fait que l'ancien
président de la république n'est pas
explicitement apporté son soutien à
madame pécresse crée des doutes créer
des interrogations et de ce point de vue
là si le soutien de nicolas sarkozy ne
constitue pas vraisemblablement un
facteur d'accélération de la campagne de
valérie pécresse le non soutien pose
problème dans une campagne qui est
aujourd'hui une campagne qui parient à
l'arrêt donc si vous voulez c'est plus
en creux qu'il faut regarder la question
du soutien nom de nicolas sarkozy que en
dynamique mais ils résident est évident
que dans un contexte vous voyez qu'un
certain nombre de figures lr notamment
par exemple monsieur woerth qui a
rejoint
monsieur macron il ya maintenant
quarante huit heures ou la mère dans une
moindre mesure la maire de calais disons
qu'il ya toute une atmosphère de doute
aujourd'hui qui s'est installée autour
de la candidature de valérie pécresse et
ça a un effet indéniable non pas tant
sur l'électorat
vraisemblablement que plutôt sûr
j'allais dire l'entourage et les
commentaires tout ça en tout cas le
participa d'une dynamique vertueuse en
faveur de valérie pécresse de oui le
valérie pécresse mais alors la question
est de savoir si elle peut payer si elle
est en mesure de se relancer le problème
de m'adapter casting si vous voulez
aujourd'hui vous ne voyez pas quelle est
la signature de 52 fin de sa campagne
c'est-à-dire il voyait pas le thème doux
lors de sa campagne et ça se savait dans
une élection présidentielle merci arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire merci
frédéric saint clar politologue
éditorialistes merci d'avoir participé à
cet échange